[Music]
while regaling you with daring stories
from her youth it might be hard to
believe your grandmother used to be a
trapeze artist however the bad backs
elbow pain and creaky knees so common in
older people is more than just old age
in fact the source of this stiffness
plagues many young people as well the
culprit is arthritis a condition that
causes inflammation and pain in the
joints of over 90 million people in the
US alone but a stiff creaky joints
really inevitable
what makes arthritis so pervasive and
why haven't we found a cure for this
widespread condition the first hurdle is
that arthritis is actually a spectrum of
over 100 different authority' conditions
all these conditions share symptoms of
joint pain and inflammation for the
origin and severity of those symptoms
vary widely even the most common type
osteoarthritis is trickier to prevent
than one might think it's a general
misconception that arthritis is confined
to old age the origins of osteoarthritis
can often be traced to a patient's early
life from any seemingly ordinary joint
injury following impact immune cells
rush in to help clean and repair the
damaged site and begin pumping out
enzymes including matrix
metalloproteinases and the Kraken eases
these enzymes clear out the damaged
tissue and contribute to inflammation
but while this rapid swelling helps
protect the joint during recovery in
adequately healed tissue can cause these
immune cells to overstay their welcome
the continuing flood of enzymes starts
to degrade the cartilage weakening the
joint and leading to arthritis later on
not all forms of arthritis can simply be
traced to an old sports injury take
rheumatoid arthritis which affects 1.3
million US adults this condition is
actually an autoimmune disease in which
Auto antibodies target natively produced
proteins some of which are secreted by
cartilage cells we still don't know what
causes this behavior but the result is
that the body treats joint tissue like a
foreign invader immune cells infiltrate
the joint despite there being no tissue
damage to repair this response leads to
chronic inflammation which destroys bone
and
College yet another condition
spondyloarthritis has similarities to
both of the conditions we've covered
patients experience continuous
information in the joints and that the
sites where ligaments and tendons attach
to bones even without any initial injury
this leads to the flood of enzymes and
degradation seen in osteoarthritis but
is driven by different inflammatory
proteins called cytokines as the enzymes
eat away at cartilage the body attempts
to stabilize smaller joints by fusing
them together this process sometimes
leads to out growths called bone spurs
which also caused intense stiffness and
joint pain with so many factors causing
arthritis our current treatments are
tailored to tackle specific symptoms
rather than the underlying causes these
range from promising macey techniques
which harvest cells from small pieces of
cartilage to grow replacement tissue to
a technique called micro fracture where
surgeons create small holes in the bone
allowing bone marrow stem cells to leak
out and form new cartilage as a last
resort
people with withered cartilage can even
undergo full joint replacements but
outside these drastic measures the
underlying drivers of autoimmune
arthritis still present a unique
treatment challenge scientists are
making progress with therapies that
block TNF alpha one of the primary
proteins causing inflammation in
rheumatoid arthritis but even this
approach only treats the symptoms of the
condition not the cause in the meantime
some of our best defenses against
arthritis are lifestyle choices
maintaining a healthy weight to take
pressure off joints low-impact exercises
like yoga or cycling and avoiding
smoking these arthritis fighting
behaviors can help us lead longer lives
as we continue to research cures and
treatments for the huge diversity of
arthritic conditions want to know what
exactly is happening in our bodies as we
age and why we age at all find out with
this video
[Music]